Jim the last program we did with you it
was just as Reagan was coming in and we
were talking about oh my gosh what are
some of the horrible things that are
going to happen as a result of the
Reagan years and can you kind of give us
a rundown and keep us and bringing us up
to date as to what things have happened
but yeah actually I think of our worst
fears are realized
I regret to say yeah it what Reagan did
and followed by Bush was actually
somewhat incredible thing in terms of
what happened in the history of American
courts because during the 12 years that
Reagan and Bush were president they set
about very carefully selecting federal
judges both in terms of age and one of
young judges who would last a long time
and in terms of ideology very carefully
choosing judges according to their
ideology in fact there were litmus test
questionnaires that had to be filled out
before he could even become named a
federal judge and altogether over the
period of time that they were there they
named 70% of the judges on the appellate
courts and the district courts that now
sit all the way from a Supreme Court
down to the trial courts so they had any
enormous impact and and the impact will
continue because of the young age of the
judges and it was a very carefully
embarked upon campaign to select judges
usually what had gone on in history
prior to that is that for example if you
had Republican president the president
would tend to pick Republicans to be
judges but there was not the ideological
litmus test that we saw in this process
in fact President Reagan at one time
bragged that the legacy he would leave
the country would be the judges
and that they would survive long after
he did into the 21st century and that
would have their impact and indeed they
have had their impact in the 12 years
that they that both Ronald Reagan and
George Bush were president and then the
few years that have come since then the
judges typically have been very activist
in a conservative direction and have
very studiously and carefully gone about
trying to dismantle a number of the
protections that had been developed for
individual rights and individual liberty
under the Constitution virtually every
time that the Supreme Court under that
was performing informed by President
Reagan to large extent virtually every
time that court ruled it ruled in favor
of big government and in favor of big
business I would say that you could
easily figure about 95% of the time the
court came down on the side of big
government and big business depending on
kind of case that was there well they
also then he said whittled away at the
rights and gains which ordinary people
and individuals have been able to get
from previous courts what are some of
those things well for example a number
of cases came up in which the Supreme
Court never directly overrule earlier
cases but they would create exceptions
and those exceptions ultimately gutted
there were so many of them that would
gut the original rule let me give you
two examples one deals with the Miranda
rule and one deals with the force
excessive force that police would use an
arrest or people that are in custody in
the first instance the court never
overruled
Miranda but would create exceptions so
they would say for example well of the
confession that was beat out of the
person with harmless harmless confession
that the person would have been
convicted anyway
well the net confession was okay they
had placed and even though they violated
morale
it was a harmless error and the second
case for example it comes up in the
context of excessive force that police
had to if police use force for example
in the confession context again if it
wasn't excessive it was as George Bush
would say a kind and gentle beating then
it didn't rise to the level of a
constitutional violation in the problem
with that kind of direction of course is
that the reason that Miranda rule came
about in the because an experience of
the country and this was particularly
true in the southwest in the South
Police generally would beat people or
would use some sort of force to get them
to sign confessions and then they would
turn around and use those confessions in
to convict somebody and while that's
also one that's bad for the individual
of course it's also bad for society
because that means quite often you're
not catching actually the criminal who
might have perpetrated the crime but
you're actually convicting the person
the police think might have done it and
in an effort to clear their own docket I
get the statistics behind them they
would convict some of they thought did
it or somebody that thought needed to be
put away so the whole purpose of Miranda
to kind of professionalize the police
force was gutted under the Reagan Bush
Supreme Court and I think that in the
way force came into play in that
decision is a very good example we also
saw backing away from a lot of the
efforts to desegregate the country for
example in terms of school districts or
breaking down affirmative action
programs or government programs to try
to hire minority businesses try to give
them a little economic boost to deal
with a history of discrimination that
they faced the court backed away and
retreated and sometimes overturned all
those earlier cases so as a result for
example here in Austin Austin's a great
a perfect example of what happened we
had a
a school desegregation plan which was
effectively dismantled by the Reagan
appointed judge who's here and that was
upheld by the Fifth Circuit Court of
Appeals which is which is dominated by
conservative Reagan bush appointees and
as a result now our school system is
back almost segregated as to the extent
that it had been prior to the
desegregation order you know so we we
didn't we haven't gotten very far
ultimately they're still doing busing
though are they not in Austin oh they're
not doing that here
no they're not the only busing it really
occurs is effort is the busing that goes
on to take advantage of the academies if
you're moving from west if you live on
one side of town you want to go to the
Academy on the east side of town you can
find busing for that and the really
unfortunate thing about this is because
the is that the desegregation plan in
Austin was actually working and I think
the most dramatic effect of that the
indicator of that was when the school
board which was a elected on this
political agenda
was considering about the whether to
dismantle the program the students all
got together and they appeared from the
school board at a very large hearing all
the students asked that the program
continue they all asked to continue
because they said they were benefiting
from the multicultural and meeting
different people and going to different
parts of town they were benefitting from
it it helped them understand what was
going on society and help their
education but regardless of what the
students wanted of course the plenty of
the school board had its own agenda and
it was sanctioned by the federal court
we now back to where we were 20 30 years
ago as a result of these cases are we
seeing a lot more police abuse yes the
court has made it very difficult to sue
police and the court has done that by
creating the good faith defense yeah you
could beat somebody up if you're doing a
good face that's exactly right yeah
that's what they said yes you beat them
up in good faith then there you have no
liability
there's a great case for this happen I
don't know if it's a great case as a sad
case in the sense but it was a Fort
Worth situation in which the jury found
that the police had used excessive force
but the court of appeals again the
federal court of appeals said well the
police acted in good faith because they
had testified that was the way they were
trained and since they were trained up
that way I was ok and they they didn't
mean that it may have violated people's
rights but they couldn't recover for the
violation of the rights because the
police were free from liability because
of good faith because of they acted in
good faith didn't have to worry about
any kind of liability so the message
that sends of course to the police is
that you can do what you want and get
away with it as long as you claim that
you're acting in good faith and to the
citizens it sends a message the police
are outside of the law and even when a
jury says that they have violated the
law nothing I mean you may have suffered
a broken arm you may be paralyzed for
life and you were shot by mistake or
whatever and there is no recovery there
is no way that you can sue and collect
damages as if you could have it happen
between two individuals and you were
hurt it was something this broader issue
I've been wanting to ask you this for a
long time over the years I've seen cases
where there was misconduct by the
prosecutor collusion with a judge
suppression of evidence and destruction
of evidence by the FBI in collusion with
a drug with a judge or other agencies
just gross misconduct on behalf of the
prosecution and judges and the FBI law
enforcement agencies and then when the
case is over
nothing happens nothing happens at all
to the judge to the effort to the L what
is there just no recourse when all this
is proven that's basically it there
really is very little recourse you can't
bring a civil rights case
in a civil in a civil case because
judges are immune from being sued
prosecutors are immune from being sued
the only thing you can hope is that you
could find a grand jury somewhere that
might indict them but of course then
that depends upon the willingness of
another prosecutor right to bring
another prosecutor in front of that
grand jury and you know the the blood
runs pretty thick in these situations so
you don't really find very many cases
where this happens virtually none and as
I say even in a civil rights case you
can't do anything I mean case after case
after case in which the judges have done
something wrong or colluded the courts
have said they cannot be sued under the
civil rights statutes and this the
Supreme Court has said over and over
even though there is massive bad
behavior illegal behavior on the part of
the prosecution of the judge and etc
that and and the poor guy was convicted
they got let the conviction stand
because he had his day in court right
it's an anomaly of the system yeah yeah
I mean you see the same thing happen to
capital punishment cases I think is just
astounding in which you may have a
situation in which the person is
convicted at trial and then a few years
later there will be evidence to come out
that very strongly suggests or almost
proves conclusively that that person is
innocent but you cannot get a hearing on
that because the court has said the
Supreme Court has said you have once
you've had a trial and that trial is
procedurally correct then that's all you
get the 14th amendment does not protect
you against being wrongly executed but
only executed without the proper
procedures is it I find that to be
pretty astounding that under the 14th
amendment is supposed to protect your
liberty and freedom me
that you could as long as you have a
fair trial then you can be executed it
doesn't ultimately matter whether or not
you are innocent as long as you've had
your trial and the Supreme Court said
well we recognize this is a great irony
of this is Rehnquist the Chief Justice
who writes this opinion and he's made
chief justice by a Ronald Reagan and he
says the traditional remedy he said we
know it happens that innocent people are
convicted we know that it happens that
innocent people are set are put on death
row but the traditional remedy that for
that is to ask the governor for clemency
now that might sound okay but in reality
it's very hard to imagine any governor
who like in Texas who campaigns on the
ability to execute people it's going to
turn around in the face of a conviction
and let that person go simply because
the Supreme Court doesn't want to handle
the case and says it throws it back to
the governor said well you can decide
whether or not to give this person
clemency we don't really care if that
person is guilty or innocent so long as
the procedures by which the person was
convicted were okay when their dissent
on that case and one of the justices
said this is nothing more than legalized
murder that's right
that was judge blackman blackman yeah
and a few months later Blackland then
can't publicly said that he had reversed
his position on death penalty in the
United States he had voted for the death
penalty quite a bit at the time that it
was there that the cases came up and he
finally reversed himself he said you
know I have sat there in my home at
night when these people come the hours
before time to be executed their lawyers
have sent briefs and I've agonized over
this and I've listened to the arguments
in the court and I finally have come to
the conclusion that even though I
philosophically believe in capital
punishment I believe that the state can
take the right to the life of somebody
in our system it cannot operate in a
neutral fashion it the system currently
operates in a discriminatory fashion
against people of color and gets poor
people
there's no way that we are capable as a
society to make sure that capital
punishment is exercised across the board
fairly and he changed his position and I
read the other day in The New York Times
that justice Powell who used to be on
the Supreme Court at one time and voted
for capital punishment has changed his
opinion in exactly the same view that
even though philosophically he's not
opposed to it in our society we are
unable to administer capital punishment
in a way that's fair and does not take
into account poverty and does not take
into account race or national origin
there are a lot of statistics which
backed this no we aren't
the statistics overwhelming that back
that up the statistics show that the
race of the victim for example plays an
enormous is an enormous factor and who
ends up on the death on death row that
is the victims white and the assailant
is black for example that the chances
are in Texas for our fortified greater
of being convicted of capital punishment
then if the victim is white and the
perpetrator is white and a lot of that
has to do with a discretion that comes
into play the prosecutor for example
gets to decide the District Attorney can
decide whether to charge the person with
murder punishable volt capital
punishment or murder punishable by life
imprisonment so that's the first step of
the discretion that comes into play the
second step of the discretion isn't
choosing the jury it's very very
difficult to choose a jury that can put
aside its own feelings and the way has
grown up the jurors have grown up in the
feelings that they have lingering
discrimination and then the jury axle
exercises the final choice whether that
person is to be sentenced to death or
not after the person is convicted all
those different factors there's a study
here in Texas that just that came out
and analyzed data between 1972 and 1988
and controlled for 35 different
factors and came to that conclusion that
the that capital punishment in Texas
is clearly levied on people according to
race according national origin and
ultimately of course according to
poverty and the unfortunate thing about
this is that this very kind of case got
in front of the US Supreme Court out of
Georgia which had a very brilliant
statistician named Baldus who has
written books and everything who did an
incredible study in Georgia and proved
statistically that it was that race
accounted for the disproportionate
number of African Americans on death row
and the Supreme Court said while this
study may be interesting as a
sociological study you can't free be
free or you can't set aside a conviction
unless you can show that the people who
convicted you intended to discriminate
against you because of race it's a it's
virtually impossible you can't can you
imagine putting a district attorney on
the stand and said you discriminate
against him on the basis of race is he
gonna say oh yeah sure I did I put the
jurors understand are they going to say
no one's gonna admit it even if they did
even if they weren't doing it
subconsciously you know they did it
consciously they're not going to do it
but there the court parts with all the
statistical evidence the degree of
probability and all of that and just
simply says hey proven by intent or
we're going to send you to the chair I
thought one of the most cynical
statements I didn't have ever seen was
when I was reading about this case and a
lot of us being pleaded before the
Supreme Court Justice Scalia said well
you're talking about people being
discriminated against being executed
because they're black if we say that's
no good then somebody can look here what
about ugly people should we give
exemptions ugly people you know what
about crippled people you know they're
just completely blowing off the real
substance and basis
what the people were challenging here
well school is a very good example of
the kind of appointment I was talking
about earlier that comes onto the
reagan-bush era very very anti civil
rights very anti civil liberties very
pro-government virtually the only thing
that Scalia is good on from my viewpoint
is on free speech issues and on that
ironically tends to be a classic
libertarian but on everything else he's
really really hostile
I mean hostile and you can see it from
his opinions in fact probably that's the
reason that Scalia is not as effective
on the court as it could be because he
is very very opinionated very sarcastic
sardonic in his opinions even with
justices who might vote like he does he
disparages them quite a bit
he's very ideological there's no way
other way to classify him and he picks
up Clarence Thomas with him Clarence
Thomas and Scalia vote almost alike and
most of the time of course is Thomas
simply signing under Scalia's opinions
yeah that is a big joke about that I
guess in Washington the fact that you
know they've kind of grafted them
together they're almost Siamese twins
now yeah and I don't know as Thomas even
written an opinion yet form you know
many many months they didn't do anything
just that their and also understand he
doesn't say much during the actual
hearing some pleadings before the court
yeah I don't think Thomas will go down
in history is one of the scholars on the
court he does that basically follow
Scalia Scalia's lean Scalia's logic
there's some talk of them sharing the
same law clerk from time to time
he's a Thomas is very strange person as
we saw during the nomination process
just in terms of personality and and the
way he approaches life and he seems to
from comments that he's made at speeches
and so on since he's been on the Supreme
Court he's retained that
facet of his personality and it was very
difficult to deal with it's as if he's
going to prove something I guess I mean
I think you're it the analogy you're
drawing was very interesting because
talking to about Scalia and Thomas being
Siamese twins I think you said when you
know Warren Berger in Harry Blackmun our
next word Nixon appointees anyone on the
court at the same time and they were
both from Minnesota they were called the
Minnesota Twins and there was a lot of
discussion about whether they were going
to swing the court to the right
you know Nixon had campaigned on
reforming the court and particularly
attacking the opinions that had made in
the area of criminal law and though to
Nixon's credit he didn't choose judges
as ideologically as Reagan and Bush and
so I think what happened then is that
when Warren Berger and Harry Blackmun
were on the court even though they had
that affinity I haven't been chosen
together having been judges together or
having come from the same state and all
that they did not black my matured as
considerably so did Berger but I
wouldn't say as much but Blackmun
actually became a very good scholar on
the corn and began to think on his own
and I don't think at all we'll see that
dynamic occur with Thomas I think that
we'll see Thomas and Scalia together
in their corner on the far right for a
long time well the United States has
we're number one I understand a few
years ago the United States incarcerated
I think we were only number three in the
world and Carr serration of its citizens
but although there were some southern
states that were surpassed the rest of
the world but now I understand the
United States incarcerated more people
than any Western civilized or
industrialized country is this the
result of the Reagan years yes to a
great step
it's a result of I think a very
unfortunate phenomenon in our society
and that is that the way you get elected
right now is by campaigning against
criminals
it's a constituency you cannot offend
because they don't vote and you campaign
against them and the way we campaign
against center that will build more
prisons and will execute more people and
so we end up with these startling
statistics are were one of the few
countries now in the modern world that
executes its people and we're one of the
few countries the top country in terms
of numbers of people that we incarcerate
Texas of course surpassing the prison
population of many countries in the
world and the problem is that we never
see any political leadership we never
see anybody say well what let's just
stop a minute folks we're spending too
much tax money and result we're getting
is not worth it all we're doing is
building more prisons it is not
economically productive in our society
it costs us twenty twenty-five thousand
dollars a year per prisoner and by what
we do by doubling our prison system as
that is our goal right now in Texas or
almost halfway there because that we
take all this dead-end money and we take
away from schools we take away from
social services we take it away from
community services and what we do is
then create the probability that that
will then be more people that we will
have to incarcerate instead of figuring
out how can we make this this was in the
private sector every politician will be
fired by now you can't we're on a prison
system the way it's being run it is not
economically feasible the the management
that had been had their heads lopped off
the board of directors would have hired
somebody new by now not only that but
the result the statistics don't show
that just putting people in jail or
executing them results in less crime no
they don't they don't at all the states
that do not have capital punishment
I have the same kind of crime rate as in
states that do have capital punishment
it has no effect whatsoever and that's
because most murder happens because of
passion it's not premeditated and so you
don't really have it isn't the capital
punishment is not deterrent everybody
now admits that nobody now argues no
matter what side of this issue you're on
nobody now argues that it's a deterrent
the only question now is whether society
is entitled to do this is vengeance
that's the only issue yeah and can
society entitled to do this as vengeance
that's all that it counted but you
figure if it takes you for a county to
execute somebody now it cost about a
million dollars all the way from the
trial process all the way through the
appeal to the Supreme Court and all of
that because you have to appoint counsel
and the way that it takes them it's
about a three or four week trial the
appeals they're about four or five
appeals that go on and it cost about a
million dollars you see some counties
now for example Dallas that last year
only sent one person in capital a sent
one person in death row because it's too
expensive you can do the same thing you
take that money and reinvest it in the
criminal justice system you can have a
better result and just put that person
away for life take that personal Society
for life and then take the money that
you would have spent to execute the
person and reinvest it in the capital
punishment be careful in the I'm sorry
in the criminal justice system Houston
which is probably the most bloodthirsty
County right now in Texas in terms of
capital punishment in fact more people
on death row from text from Harris
County than from most of the countries
in the world that still do have capital
punishment and for most of the states
there are more people on death row from
Harris County than from most of the
states in the Union right now that's how
many people are coming out of Harris
County but because of that their courts
in Harris County are going to be tied up
until the year 2020 right now doing
nothing but capital punishment trials
and how does that help our criminal
justice system it doesn't you take the
twenty to twenty-five thousand dollars
it cost you per year to house somebody
imagine what you can do in terms of
rehabilitating that person or investing
it to deal with that person because
because most crimes which people are in
prison right now are not violent crimes
they come out of basically poverty how
to make it on the streets and take that
money and for less than the $25,000 that
it costs to incarcerate them you could
do something so that they wouldn't be in
a dead-end and we wouldn't have to
support them it would be a more
productive Society there is one benefit
because martyrs as people that happens
when they are in prison and that is they
learn a lot more on how to commit crimes
yeah I was talking to a fellow who had
spent a little bit of time in jail
before his case was dismissed
he said they spent so much time talking
about how not to get caught new scams
and when they watched television they
watched the police programs on
television they look to see how what
what works and what doesn't and even
that falls in it comes into this
equation on how to be better criminals
absolutely yeah that's right we know the
programs right now that you have in
prison work they don't don't work
because they spend most of time the
prisoners spend most their time with
other prisoners learning how to be
better criminals when they get out it's
because the culture that's there in the
prison you know once you get somebody in
the prison system you can count on the
recidivism that person going back into
prison later on means somewhere like 40
to 60 percent it it we we don't look at
this as an economic issue in terms of
what it's doing to our society we let
the politicians drum beat this issue and
it just sort of becomes cyclical they
drum beat it
we parrot it they parrot us we parrot
them again and it goes on and on and on
without ever stopping to think wow why
are we taking all this money away from
the education system to build prisons
I mean people now in Texas are competing
to have a prison put in their County
because they want the economic benefit
from it it's crazy it's crazy they ought
to take the same money and build a
college or build a school or invested in
economic
development instead of putting into
dead-end things like like prisons and
the other bad thing about this Frank is
that 10 to 20% of the people right now
in prison are there because they're
mentally disabled they're either you
have mental illness or mental
retardation and and what happened and
they're there because of what's
happening is that we shut down the
institutions now instead of providing
for Community Housing and Community
Programs
to help deal with people that have
mental disability they're on the streets
and so they engage in a lot of what we
would call antisocial behavior and they
end up in prison and then when they get
out of prison there is no way no program
for them to hook into so they get back
out in the same activity they don't know
a lot of the you have someone that has
been on retardation has an IQ for
example of 70 does not understand the
concept of dealing with a parole officer
so they're out on the streets and they
get their parole revoked because I'm not
dealing with a parole officer and
they're back in prison again they have a
recidivism rate of 80% not only that but
a lot of the people that come out I
represent some people in a case right
now we're doing in this issue we have
two women who when they were released
from prison were simply put on a bus one
went to Houston and one was supposed to
be going to El Paso and she ended up in
Los Angeles both women were raped on the
street and repeatedly abused and
eventually had the parole revoked
because an reporter the parole officer
and we're back in the paralysis back in
the prison system it doesn't make any
sense but that's why we're dealing with
these issues right now as a society
because of the way they were politicized
we don't have any leaders with guts to
simply say let's re-evaluate this
program let's deal with it in a
different way you've been working have
certain cases concerning civil rights in
high school
yeah actually I thought the courts have
said that those kids have no right what
I've seen no rights at all well they
have direct you yeah we may we lose
these cases they won't have anything
whatsoever these are cases that are
brought under a federal law called title
9 which is part of the education
amendments and if that law prohibits sex
discrimination schools and we have two
cases a whole section sex yeah and what
we we have two cases involving Bryan
independent school district and which
two three girls actually or very
severely is sexually harassed touched
and groped insulted all sorts of bad
language over a period of time but in
the school bus by other students boys on
the buses in the classroom in the
hallways administration knew about it or
the whole history of complaints and the
district did nothing and ironically we
got these complaints at the same time
that the American Association of
University Women released their report
talking about the the pervasiveness of
sexual harassment in the schools at
eighty percent of the students in some
fashion or another have suffered sexual
harassment and something like if I
recall this correctly 25 or 30 percent
maybe it's high as forty it actually had
physical harassment occur so it is an
extremely pervasive problem is something
that we never talked about for a long
time right it was much like child abuse
we never talked about it for a long time
in our society but it is a very severe
problem and the question now is whether
the school administrators and they know
this is going on and they fail to
discipline the students whether this
isn't a violation of federal law and
will be litigating those in federal
court and I think I have a big impact
upon what goes on in the schools because
of administrators begin to understand
that they are responsible for making
sure this doesn't happen
or when it does happen for punishing
them then they're gonna have a whole
different attitude toward this you know
the editor they have right now and send
us well you know these are teenage boys
yeah you know so what I mean part of the
idea of going to school is to learn how
to function in society and we don't
tolerate this not supposed to tolerate
this in our economic sector or any other
sector after you're 18 if you don't
teach kids this whether in school what
is the message you're teaching them that
they're supposed to be doing that they
should be doing or not be doing when
they get out but we'll see yeah we'll
see what happens how favorable the
judges will be I don't know if there's
any validity of this I'd seems to me
that much of this has recurred after the
Reagan administration came in during the
60s and 70s it was considered really bad
form when people are fine with women's
liberation and the men were more we're
responding to this and and the genders
were more equal becoming more equal but
then all these barriers seemed to fall
apart during the Reagan administration
and I began to hear racist remarks
around schools and on CB radios overtly
racist and sexist and so I wonder if
this harassment has started back there
started up just in the past as ice age
since 1980s or whether something's been
going on all the time
and we just didn't address it as a
problem well I think it maybe put your
your your finger on it by talking about
the president because I think to a large
extent the administration sets the
cultural tone for the country and if the
cultural tone for the country is we need
to do away with discrimination we have
to end races and we have to do away with
sexual harass
then that kind of behavior you're
talking about is unacceptable or at
least more unacceptable than usual but
at the tone of the country becomes or
the tone set by the administration
becomes without folks isn't quite as bad
we don't look upon this the same disdain
that was looked upon in an earlier
administration then I think what you see
as you see a rise in that kind of
behavior occur see I think you know the
reagan-bush drum beating that went on
about affirmative action was that it was
you know when they start talking about
affirmative action being racial
preference and all that kind of stuff
anybody who looks at an affirmative
action program knows it's not about
quarter quarters it's not about
preferences none of that stuff is in an
affirmative action program the way the
way they're designed and used but
there's a myth that's created that
that's exactly what they are you know
you're here Reagan telling these
anecdotes or you know he was he governed
by anecdote almost you know it was a
great disservice to the country in a
sense and he was set this so what it
becomes you start attacking affirmative
action programs it becomes a way as a
message that's sent to society race is
doing away with racial discrimination no
longer as a priority in this country and
I think that's the real problem in what
he does with the courts of course I
think is bad that has been damaging but
the whole mood that we lived under for
12 years yeah
it sets up this culture that allows and
countenance as a sort of activity to
occur it really in a sense sets us back
because if you look at kind of a
historical continuum that we go through
you know from the 40s into the 50s and
the 60s about changing the way we
treated women or the way that we treated
minorities you'll see that these twelve
years are really a setback
over the whole course of history I'm
sure that in 50 years from now we'll
look back and we'll see that during this
period there was a low sort of like in
the early part of the Reagan years it
was a la I'm sorry of the Eisenhower
years it was kind of a law in this and
for the 12 years that Reagan and Bush
were there I think we'll probably see
it'll even cast worse than alone it'll
be a step or two backwards from which we
have to recover you know in our progress
as a society and I guess how can this be
done groups individuals like you and
groups like the Texas Civil Rights
Project are in the forefront of this
what just about ordinary American people
we know American people can do a lot I
mean individuals we do a lot as
individuals I mean if you look at what
we do is volunteers with Boy Scouts and
with PTA and in school groups and in
helping in soup kitchens know that
individuals in our in our country really
do a lot incredible amount of work for
people and people but part of the thing
that we can do is that in our work that
way we can use that process as a way of
educating and when we hear racism or we
hear sexism or we see something happen
we need to talk up sometimes we defer a
lot right as well you know people are
entitled to their views and stuff and
people aren't entitled to their views
but you're also entitled to say hey you
know we really do we really wanna be
talking like that and we got to go
sometimes when issues touch us or we
particularly discuss it with something
go down to the City Council and complain
about it go to the school board and
complain you don't have to go there all
the time but if everybody didn't once in
a while we'd be a lot further off I mean
I'm sure a lot of people are very
disgusted about some of the censorship
going on over religious agenda in public
schools but to go down there say Council
I mean down to the school board
complaint but it's a very important
thing write letters to the editor very
important thing a lot of people can do
that it doesn't take a lot of effort but
people can do that and people didn't are
jaques they also need to think things
through there's a lot of talk show stuff
going on right now and guess as we sit
here talking a lot of talk show stuff
going on in in which people I think know
some sometimes don't
stop and think about the code words that
are used and stop to think and stop and
think about what really is going on in
this talk show and sort of accept some
of the stuff they hear this drumbeat of
cynicism that President Clinton referred
to I think it's one thing to criticize
and I think that we need to do that
we've got to do that and we have to but
we have to do it we have to do it in a
way it's constructive you know the thing
that's going on right now is that we
don't need here a debate about
healthcare right we don't hear debate we
hear a debate about what Clinton did as
a governor some years ago or may have
done or may not have done and you know
you really think about it what this is
deflecting us from something that's of
great importance to an enormous number
of people that we see on the streets
that we know a lot of people that we
know can't get health care anymore it
used to get health care can't get
anymore and health care for a lot of
people is a very oppressive issue
particularly if you older or if you have
kids that there can be chronically sick
it's a very very oppressive issue and we
don't hear the debate going on about
that you know that we ought to have you
know how are we going to make our system
better than what it is I think
individuals have got to do that we
really got to accept that responsibility
and do it